the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
it's my does my data come from a
particular distribution and why we would
want to know this well maybe we're
interested in for example you know
knowing if the zodiac signs of the
fortune 500 CEOs are uniformly
distributed or maybe we actually have
slightly more slightly deeper endeavors
such as understanding if you can
actually apply the t-test by testing
normality of your sample all right so we
saw that there's the main result is the
main standard test for this it's called
the comb over off smirnoff test that
people use quite a bit it's probably one
of the most used tests out there and
there's other versions of it that I
mentioned passing by there's no crime or
von mises and there's the Anderson
Dowling test now how would you pick one
of such tests well you know there always
are gonna they're always gonna have
their advantages and disadvantages and
common grasmere enough is definitely the
most widely used because well I guess
because it's a natural notion of
distance between functions and just look
for each point how far they can be and
you just look at the farthest they can
be everywhere now you know crap ever
misses involves altri distance so if
you're not used to you know Hilbert
spaces or notions of you know Euclidean
spaces at least it's a little more
complicated and then Anderson Dowling is
definitely even more complicated now
each of these tests is going to be more
powerful against other alternatives so
unless you can really guess which
alternative you're expecting to see
which you probably don't because again
you're in a case where you want
typically declare h0 to be the correct
one then it's really you know a matter
of tossing a coin maybe you can run all
three of them and just sleep what better
at night because all three of a mess
fail to reject for example all right so
as I mentioned one of the
maybe primary goals to test goodness the
fittest it is to be able to check
whether we can apply students test right
and if the student distribution is
actually valid distribution and for that
we need to have normally distributed
data now as I said several times
normally distributed it's not a specific
distribution it's a family of
distribution that's indexed by means and
variances and the way I would want to
test if a distribution is normally
distributed is well I would just look at
the most natural normal distribution or
Gaussian distribution that my data could
follow that means that's the Gaussian
distribution that has the same mean as
my data in the same empirical variance
as my data all right and so I'm gonna be
given some points x1 xn and I'm gonna be
asking are those Gaussian that means
this is equivalent to say are they n Mu
Sigma square for some Mu Sigma squared
and of course the natural choice is to
take new hat to be new to be equal to MU
hat which is xn bar and Sigma squared to
be Sigma squared hat to be well SN hat
SN what we wrote SN which is 1 over n
sum from I equal 1 to N of X I minus xn
bar squared ok so this is definitely the
natural one you would want to test and
maybe you could actually just close your
eyes and just stuff that in a Croma
graph smirnoff test ok so here there's a
few things that don't work the first one
is that the dance curse theorem does not
work anymore right downstairs theorem
was the one that told us that you know
properly normalized this thing would
actually convert to the supremum of a
Brownian bridge which is not true so
that's one problem but there's actually
an even bigger problem is that this
distribution we will check in a second
actually does not is pivotal itself
right this this this statistic is
pivotal it does not have a distribution
that depends on unknown parameters which
is sort of nice at least under the null
however the distribution is not this
same as the one that had fix mu and
Sigma the fact that they come from some
random variables is actually distorting
the distribution itself and in
particular the quintiles are going to be
distorted and we hinted at that last
time so one of the thing I need to tell
you though is that this thing actually
so I know there's some there's I yeah
that's where that's where there's a word
missing so we compute the quantiles for
this test statistic and so what I need
to promise to you is that this quintiles
do not depend on any unknown parameter
right I mean it's not clear this right
so I want to test whether my data has
some Gaussian distribution so under the
know all I know is that my my X eyes are
Gaussian with some U and some variance
Sigma which I don't know so it could be
the case that when I try to understand
the distribution of this quantity under
the null it depends on mu and Sigma
which I don't know so we need to check
that this is the case and what's
actually our redemption here is actually
going to be the supreme em the supremum
is going to basically allow us to say
soup out mu N and Sigma squared so let's
check that right so what I'm interested
in is this quantity supremum over T in
are of the difference between FN of T
and what I write Phi nu hat Sigma
squared of T so Phi nu hat Sigma hat
squared sorry Sigma hat squared is the
CDF of some Gaussian with mean mu hat
and variance Sigma hat squared and so in
particular this thing here Phi hat of
new hat
sorry Phi hat of new hat Sigma hat
squared of T is the probability that
some X is less than T where X follows
some n mu hat Sigma hat squared
so what it means is that by just the
translation and scaling trick that we
typically do for Gaussian to turn it
into some standard Gaussian that implies
that there exist some Z which is
standard Gaussian this time so mean zero
and variance one such that X is equal to
Sigma hat X sorry z plus mu hat agreed
that's that's basically saying that X
has some Gaussian with mean mu and
variance Sigma Square and I'm not gonna
say the hats every single times okay so
okay so that's what it means so in
particular maybe I shouldn't use X here
because the X is gonna be my actual data
so let me write Y okay so now what is
the what is this guy here it's basically
so Phi hat so this implies that phi mu
hat Sigma hat squared of T is equal to
the probability that Sigma hat Z plus mu
hat is less than T which is equal to the
probability that Z is less than T minus
mu hat divided by Sigma hat right
but now when Z is a standard normal this
is really just the cumulative
distribution function of a standard
Gaussian but evaluated at a point which
is not T but T minus mu hat divided by
Sigma hat all right so in particular
what I know so from this what I get well
maybe I'll remove that it's gonna be
annoying I know that Phi new hat Sigma
hat squared Phi new hat Sigma hat
squared of T is simply Phi of say zero
one and that's just a notation usually
we don't put those but here it's more
convenient so it's Phi zero one of t
minus mu hat divided by Sigma hat okay
that's just something you can quickly
check there's this nice way of writing
the community of distribution function
for n
mean and any variance in terms of the
cumulative distribution function with
mean zero and variance one alright not
too complicated
alright so now what I'm gonna say is
that okay I have this soup here so what
I can write is that this thing here is
equal to the soup over T in R of 1 over
and let me write what FN is sum from I
equal 1 to N of the indicator that X I
is less than t minus phi0 one of t minus
mu hat divided by Sigma hat ok I
actually want to make a change of
variable so that this thing I'm gonna
calm you are you sorry okay and so I'm
gonna make my life easier and I'm gonna
make it appear here and so I'm just
gonna replace this by indicator that X I
- new hats divided by Sigma hat less
than t minus mu hat divided by Sigma hat
which is sort of useless at this point
I'm just making my formula more
complicated but now I see something here
that shows up and I will call it u and
this is another you ok so now what it
means is that souping over T when T
ranges from negative infinity to plus
infinity the new range is from negative
infinity to plus infinity right so this
soup I can actually write the soup in T
I can write as a soup in you so it's
decatur that x i minus mu hat divided by
sigma hat is less than u minus phi0 one
of you now let's pause for one second
let's see where we're going what we're
trying to show that this thing does not
depend on the unknown parameters say mu
and Sigma which are the mean and the
variance of X under the knot to do that
we basically need to make only
quantities that are
sort of invariant under there's values
so I try to make this thing invariant
under anything it's just really
something that depends on nothing is the
CDF it does only pen of Sigma hat and mu
hat anymore
but Sigma hat and new hats will depend
on mu and Sigma right I mean they're
actually good estimators of those guys
so they should be pretty close to them
and so I need to make sure that I'm not
actually doing anything wrong here
so the key thing here is going to be to
observe that 1 over N sum from icon want
you and of indicator of X I minus mu hat
divided by Sigma hat less than u which
is the first term that I have in this
absolute value well this is what well
this is equal to 1 over N sum from I
equal 1 to N of indicator that well now
under the null which is that X follows
and nu Sigma squared for some mu and
Sigma squared that are unknown but they
are here they exist I just don't know
what they are then X I minus Mew can be
written as Sigma Z I plus mu minus nu
hat divided by Sigma hat where Z is
equal to X minus mu divided by Sigma
right that's just the same trick that I
wrote here ok nobody agrees I just
standardized sorry Z yeah so Zi is X I
minus mu I minus mu divided by Sigma all
right just the standardization so now
once I write this I can actually divide
everybody by Sigma right I just divided
on top here and at the bottom here so
now what I need to check is that the
distribution of this guy does not depend
on mu or Sigma that's what I claim what
is the distribution of this indicator
it's a Bernal a'right
and so if I want to understand its
distribution all I need to do is to
compute its expectation which is just
the probability that this thing happens
but the probability that this thing
happens is actually not depending on you
and Sigma and the reason is that mu is
what well it's X bar sorry yeah so new
hat sorry is xn bar so mu hat minus mu
which under the null follows and mu
sigma square over N right that's the
property of the average so when I do mu
hat minus mu divided by Sigma this thing
is what distribution it's still a normal
it's a linear transformation remember
what are the parameters yeah 0 1 over N
but this does not depend
on mu or Sigma right now I need to check
that this guy does not depend on your
Sigma what is the distribution of Sigma
hat - say over Sigma yeah it is a chi
square so this is actually sorry Sigma
hat squared divided by Sigma squared is
a chi squared with n minus 1 degrees of
freedom does not depend on your Sigma oh
yeah thank you so this is actually
divided by it so maybe this guy let's
write it like that this is the proper
way of writing it I think right so now I
have those two things
neither of them depends on your Sigma I
have those two things there's just one
more thing to check what is it that
they're independent right because the
dependence in U and Sigma could be
hidden in the covariance it could be the
case that the marginal distribution of
MU does not depend on New York Sigma the
marginal distribution of Sigma of new
hat does not depend on you see the
marginal distribution of Sigma hat does
not depend on your Sigma but their
correlation could depend on you and
Sigma but we also have that if I look at
the so if I look at so since new hat is
independent of Sigma hat it means that
the Joint Distribution
of new hats divided by Sigma and Sigma
hat divided by Sigma does not depend on
dava on mu and Sigma okay agreed it's
not in the individual ones and it's not
in there the way they interact with each
other it's nowhere Yakko currents
theorem right so that's something we've
been using over and again that's all
under the know if my data is not
Gaussian nothing of the nothing actually
holds I just used the fact that under
the null i'm gaussian for some mean mu
and variance Sigma squared but that's
all I care about when I'm designing a
test I only care about that is the the
distribution of the null at least to
control the type 1 error then to control
the type 2 error then you know I crossed
my fingers pretty hard ok so now this
basically implies what's written on the
board that this distribution this test
statistic does not depend on any unknown
parameters it's just something that's
pivotal in particular I could go at the
back of a book and check if there's a
table for the quintiles of those things
and indeed there are this is the table
that you see so actually this is not
even in a book this is in lis divorce
originals paper 1967 as you can tell
from the typewriting and and you know he
actually you know probably was rolling
some dice from his office back in the
day and was checking that this was a you
know he simulated and this is how we
computed those numbers and here you also
have some little limiting distribution
which is not the soup of a Brownian
motion over 0
one of sorry of a brown bridge over zero
one which is the one that you would see
for the coma grafts we're enough tests
but it's something that's slightly
different and as I said this numbers are
actually typically much smaller than the
numbers you would get right remember we
got something that was about 0.5 I think
or maybe 0.41 for the kolmogorov-smirnov
test at the same entrance which means
that using comma gruffly the force test
is going to be harder for you not to
reject with the same data it might be
the case that in one case you reject and
in the other one you fail to reject
but the ordering is always that if you
fail to reject with coma gruffly force
you will fail to reject with comb-over
of smirnoff right there's always one so
that's why people tend to close their
eyes and prefer comb-over smirnoff
because it just makes their life easier
okay so this is called coma gruffly
force I think there's actually an e here
sorry an eye before the e doesn't matter
too much okay I'm there any questions
yes
yeah so so the fact that it's actually a
different distribution is that here so
if I actually knew what mu and Sigma
were I would do exactly the same thing
but here reven and having this average
with mu and Sigma I would just have the
average with new hat and Sigma hat I
would just have the average with mu and
Sigma okay so what it means is that the
key thing is that what I would compare
is the one over and some of some
Bernoulli's with parameter and the
parameter here would be the probability
that mu X I minus mu over Sigma is less
than u which is just the probability
that Phi sorry
it's a bernly with probability F of T
well let me write that what it is right
so that's minus Phi 0 1 of T ok so
that's for the KS test and then I soup
over T right that's what I would have
had because this is actually exactly the
right thing here I would remove the true
mean I would divide by the true standard
deviation so that would actually end up
being a standard Gaussian and that's why
I'm allowed to use Phi 0 1 here agreed
and these are Bernoulli's because
they're just indicators what happens in
the comb-over of Lili force test well
here the birnley the only thing that's
going to change is this guy right they
still have a Bernal a it's just that the
parameters of the Bernalillo weird the
parameters of the Bern alike it's it
becomes the probability that some n0 1
plus some and 0 1 over N
right / some square roots of K squared
and minus 1 divided by n is less than T
and those things are independent but
those guys are not necessarily
independent right and so what why is
this probably changing well because this
denominator is actually fluctuating a
lot so that actually makes this
probability different and so that's
basically where it comes from right so
you could probably convince yourself
very quickly that this only makes those
guys closer and why does it make those
guys closer no sorry it makes those guys
farther right and it makes those guys
farther for very clear reason is that
this the expectation of this Bertoni is
exactly that guy here it's oh I think
it's gonna be true as well that the
expectation of this Bernoulli is gonna
be that guy but the fluctuations are
gonna be much bigger than just if I had
de bernalillo because the first thing I
do is I have a random parameter for my
Bernoulli and then I flip differently so
the fluctuations are gonna be bigger
than a Bernal and so when I take the
scoop I'm gonna have to pay them so it
makes things farther apart which makes
it more likely for you to reject yeah
yeah it means that Lily force is harder
not to reject us because we reject when
we larger than the number so the number
being smaller with the same data we
might be right so basically it looks
like this what we run so here we have
the distribution for the so let's say
this is the density for KS and then we
have the density for L comma graph lily
force KL okay
and what the density of Kea looks like
it looks like this right and so if I
want to squeeze in alpha here I'm gonna
have to squeeze in and I spit in alpha
here then this is the quintile of order
1 minus alpha well let's say alpha of
the KL and this is the quintile alpha of
TS so now you give me data and what I do
is that I check whether they are larger
than this number so if I apply key s I
check whether I'm larger or smaller than
this thing but if I apply comma girl
fleetly force I check whether I'm large
or small in this thing so with this
entire range of values for my test
statistic because it is the same test
statistic I just plugged in mu hat and
Sigma hat for this entire range the two
tests of different outcomes and this is
a big range in practice right I mean
it's between its don't let sits I mean
it's pretty much on scat scale here okay
n equal yeah yeah this should become the
same very far
let me see though because right so here
we have eight so here we have say four
point five we get point eight eight six
and four key oh I don't have it
yeah actually sorry so you write your
totally right
this is the Brownian bridge values
because in the limit by C Slutsky sorry
yeah these are the values that you get
for the Brownian bridge because in the
limit by Slutsky this thing is gonna
have no fluctuation and this thing is
gonna have no fluctuation so they're
just gonna be pinned down and it's gonna
look like as if I did not replace
anything because in the limit I know
those guys much faster the MU hat and
Sigma hat converge much faster to mu and
Sigma then the distribution itself
alright so those are actually gonna be
negligible you're right actually even I
didn't have these are actually the
numbers I showed you for the bridge to
the Brown bridge last time because I
didn't have it for the comb-over of
smirnoff one okay
so there's actually so those are
numerical ways of checking things right
I give you data you just crank the comb
over of smirnoff test usually you press
f5 on MATLAB but let's say you actually
compute this entire thing and there's a
number that comes out and you decide
whether it's large enough for small
enough of course statistical software is
gonna make your life even simpler by
spitting out a p-value because you can I
mean if you can compute quintiles you
can also point compute P values and so
you know your life is just fairly easy
you just have you know red is bad Green
is good and then you can go the problem
is that those are numbers you want to
rely on but let's say you actually
reject let's say you reject your p-value
is actually just like slightly below 5%
so you can say well maybe I'm just gonna
change my my my p-value my threshold to
1% but you might want to see what's
happening and for that you need a visual
diagnostics like how do I check if
something departs from being normal for
example how do I check if a distribution
why is the distribution not a uniform
distribution why is the distribution not
an exponential distribution there's many
ways right if I have an exponential
distribution and that first half of my
values are negative for example well
there's like pretty obvious reasons why
it should not be exponential but it
could be the case that is just the tails
are all heavier or the there's more
concentration at some point maybe it has
two modes there's things like this but
the real thing we don't believe that the
Gaussian is so important because it
looks like this close to zero what we
like about the Gaussian is that the
tails here decay at this rate
exponential minus x squared over two
that we described in the maybe first
lecture and in particular if they were
like kinks around here it wouldn't
matter too much this is not what makes
issues for the Gaussian and so what we
want is to have visual diagnostic that
tells us if the tails of my distribution
are comparable to the tails of a
Gaussian one for example and those are
what's called quantile quantile plots
and in particular or QQ plots and the
various the the basic QQ plots we're
going to be using are the ones that are
called normal QQ plots that are
comparing your data to a Gaussian
distribution or a normal distribution
but in general you could be comparing
your data to any distribution you want
and the way you do this is by comparing
the quintiles of your data the empirical
quintiles
to the quintiles of the actual
distribution you're trying to compare
yourself to so this in a way is visual
way of performing this goodness of fit
test and what's nice about visual is
that there's room for debate you can see
something that somebody else cannot see
and you can always because you want to
see that things are Gaussian and we'll
see some examples where you can actually
see it if you are you know good at
debate but it's actually going to be
clearly not
all right so this is a quick and easy
check that's something I do all the time
you give me data I'm just gonna run this
one of the first thing I do so I can
check if I can start you know entering
the gaussian world without you know
compromising myself too much and the
idea is to say well if f is close to if
F if my data comes from a F and if I
know that FN is close to F then rather
than computing some norm some number
that tells me how far they are
summarizing how far they are I could
actually plot the two functions and see
if they are far apart so let's let's
think for one second what this kind of a
plot would look like well I would go
between 0 and 1 that's where everything
would happen let's say my distribution
is the Gaussian distribution so this is
the CDF of n 0 1 and now I have this guy
that shows up and remember we had this
piecewise constant ok let's say we get
something like this we get a piecewise
constant distribution for for F n right
just from this and even despite my bad
skills at drawing it's clear that it's
gonna be hard for you to distinguish
those two things even for a fairly large
amount of points because the problem is
gonna happen here and those guys look
pretty much the same everywhere you are
here you're gonna see differences maybe
in the middle but we don't care too much
about those differences and so what's
gonna happen is that you're gonna want
to compare those two things and this is
basically you have the information you
want but visually just doesn't render
very well because you're not scaling
things properly and the way we actually
do it is by flipping things around and
rather than comparing the plot of F to
the plot of FN we compare the plot of f
inverse to the plot of f inverse now if
F goes from the real line to the
interval 0 1 F inverse goes through goes
from 0 1 to the whole real line so
what's gonna happen is that I'm gonna
compare things on some
intervals which is the intent which are
the entire real line and then what
values should I be looking those things
at well technically for F if F is
continuous I could look at f inverse for
any value that I please right so I have
F and if I want to look at F inverse I
pick a point here and I look at the
value that it gives me and that's F
inverse of say you write if this is U
and I could pick any value I want I'm
gonna be able to find it the problem is
that when I start to have this piecewise
constant thing I need to decide what
value I assigned for anything that's in
between two jumps right and so I can
choose whatever I want but in practice
is just gonna be things that I myself
the side maybe I can decide that this is
the value maybe I can decide that the
value is here but for all these guys I'm
gonna pretty much decide always the same
value right if I'm in between for this
value you for this jump the jump is here
so if for this value I'm gonna be able
to decide whether I want to go above or
below but it's always this value that's
gonna come out so rather than picking
values that are in between I might as
well just pick only values for which
this is the value that it's gonna get
and those values are exactly 1 / + - / +
3 / + 4 / and it all the way to n over N
all right that's exactly where the flat
parts are we know we jump from 1 over n
every time and so that's exactly the
recipe it says look at those values 1
over n 2 over n 3 over N risky until say
n minus 1 over N and for those values
compute the inverse of both the
empirical CDF and the true CDF now for
the empirical CDF it's actually easy I
just told you this is basically where
the points are where the jumps occur and
the jumps occur where well exactly at my
observations now remember I need to sort
those observations to talk about them so
the one that occurs for the ice jump is
the ice largest observation which we
denoted by as X sub parentheses I
remember we had this formula that
we said well we have X 1 X n these are
my data and what I'm going to sort them
into is X sub 1 parentheses which is
less than or equal to X sub 2
parentheses which is less than X sub n
parentheses okay so we just ordered them
from smallest to largest and you know
we've done that we just put this
parenthesis notation so in particular F
and inverse of I over N is the location
where the ice jumps occur which is the
eighth-largest observation
okay so for this guy this values the y
axes are actually fairly easy
I know it's basically my ordered
observations the X values are well that
depends on the function f I'm trying to
test if it's the Gaussian is just the
quintile of order 1 minus 1 over N right
is this Q 1 minus 1 over n here that I
need to compute is the inverse of the
cumulative distribution function which
given the formula for F you can actually
compute or maybe estimate fairly well
but it's something that you can find in
tables those are basically quintiles
inverse of CDF or quintiles right and so
that's basically the things we're
interested in that's why it's called
quintile quintile those are the some
sometimes referred to as theoretical
quantiles the one we're trying to test
and empirical quintiles the one that
correspond to the empirical CDF and so
I'm plotting a plot where the x axis is
quintile the y axis is quintile and so I
call this plot a quintic went out loud
or QQ plot because just say 10 times
quintile quintile and then you'll see
why yeah well that's just that we're
back to the we're back to the goodness
of fit test right so if you look at so
you don't do it yourself that's the
simple answer to you don't I just I'm
just telling you how those plots that
you're gonna be seen spit out from a
software are gonna look like now
depending on the software there's a
different thing that's happening some
software's are actually plotting F with
the right let's say you want to do
quanta normal as you asked so you're
some software are just gonna use f to be
with new hat and Sigma hat and that's
why some software are actually not gonna
do this they're just gonna use a
Gaussian but then they're gonna actually
have a different reference point so what
do we want to see here what should
happen if all these points if all my
points actually come from F from a
distribution that has CDF F what should
happen what should I see well since F n
should be close to F f n inverse should
be close to F inverse which means that
this point should be close to that point
this point should be close to that point
so ideally if I actually picked the
right F
I should see a plot that looks like this
something where all my points are very
close to the line y is equal to X right
and I'm gonna have some fluctuations but
something very close to this now that's
if F is exactly the right one if F is
not exactly the right one in particular
in the case of a Gaussian one if I
actually plotted here the quantiles so
if I plotted ff01
of T right so let's say those are the
ones I actually plot but I really don't
know what new hat is not zero and Sigma
hat is not zero and so this is not the
one I should be getting since we
actually know that Phi of new hat Sigma
hat squared T is equal to Phi zero one
of t minus mu hat divided by Sigma hat
there's just this change of axis which
is actually very simple this change of
axis is just a simple translation
scaling which means that this this line
here is going to be transformed into
another line with a different slope and
a different intercept and so some
software will actually decide to go with
this
curve and just show you what the
reference curve should be rather than
actually putting everything back onto
the 45-degree curve any straight line
you're happy I mean depending on the
software because if the software
actually really rescaled this thing do
you have new hat in Sigma square and you
find a different line then you're in a
different straight line this is bad news
which is not gonna happen actually it's
impossible that happens because you've
actually said well no it could if you're
if it's crazy it could it should be very
crazy okay so let's see what our does
for us for example so here in our our
actually does this funny trick where so
here I did not actually plot the lines I
should actually add the line so the
command is like QQ norm of my sample
right and that's really simple I just
stack all my data into some vector say X
and I say QQ norm of X and it just spits
this thing out okay very simple but I
could actually add another command which
I can't remember I think it's like Q
line and it's just gonna add the line on
top of it but if you see actually what R
does for us it's actually doing the
translation and scaling on the axes
themselves so it actually changes the X
and y axis in such a way that when you
look at your picture and you forget
about what the meaning of the axes are
the relevant straight line is actually
still the 45-degree line so because it's
actually done the change of of units for
you so you don't have to even see the
line you know that in your mind that
this is basically the reference line is
still 45 degree because that's the way
the the axes are made but if I actually
put my axis right so here for example it
goes from let's look at some well okay
those are all square yeah and that's
probably because I actually have as the
samples are actually from a standard
normal so I did not make my life very
easy to illustrate your question but of
course I didn't know you were gonna ask
it next time let's just prepare
let's script more we'll seen another one
in the next law but so here what you
expect to see is that all the plots
should be on the 45-degree line right
this is there should be the right one
and if you see when I start having
10,000 samples this is exactly what's
happening so this is a good as good as
it gets this is an n0 one plotted
against the theater quantile of an N 0 1
as good as it gets
if you see for the second one which is
50 sample size of size sample of size 50
there is some fudge factor right I mean
those things were doesn't look like
there's a straight line right sort of
appears that there's some weird things
happening here at the lower tail and the
reason why this is happening is because
we're trying to compare the tails right
when I look at this picture the only
thing that goes wrong somehow is always
at the tip because those are sort of
rare and extreme values and they're sort
of all over the place and so things are
never really super smooth and super
clean so this is what your best shot is
this is what you've ever will ever hope
to get so size 10 right so you have 10
points remember we actually well I
didn't really tell you how to deal with
the extreme cases because the problem is
that F inverse of 1 for the true F is
plus infinity so you have to make some
sort of weird boundary choices to decide
what F inverse of 1 is and it's
something that's like somewhere but you
still want to put like 10 dots right 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 dots so I have 10
observations you will see 10 dots I have
50 observations you will see 50 dots
remember right because I have there are
1 over N 2 over N 3 over and all the way
to n over n I didn't tell you the last
one
okay so this is when things go well and
this is when things should not go well
ok so here actually the distribution is
a student team with 15 degrees of
freedom which should depart somewhat
from a Gaussian distribution that tails
should be heavier and what you can see
is basically the following is that for
10 you actually see something that's
crazy right if I do ten observations but
if I do 50 observations honestly it's
kind of hard to see that it's different
from this their normal so you could
still be happy with this for 100 and
this is what's happening for 10,000 and
even here it's not the beautiful
straight line but it feels like you
would be still tempted to conclude that
it's a beautiful straight line so let's
try to guess so basically there's four
each of those sides there's two
phenomena either it goes like this or it
goes like this
and then it goes like this or goes like
this each side corresponds to the left
tail there's all the smallest values so
that's the left side and that's the
right side corresponds to the large
values okay and so basically you can
actually think of some sort of a table
that tells you what your QQ plot looks
like and so let's say it looks like so
we have our reference 45-degree line so
let's say this is the QQ plot that's
that could be one thing this could be
the QQ plot where I have another thing
that's then I can do this guy and then I
do this guy okay so are the four cases
okay and here what's changing is the
right tail and we hear what's changing
is the and when I go from here to here
what changes is the left tail is that
true no sorry what changes here is the
right tail as this part that changes
from top to bottom so here's something
about right tail and tear that something
about left tail everybody understands
what I mean when I talk about tails okay
and so here is just gonna be a question
of whether the tails are heavier or
lighter than the Gaussian everybody you
understand what I mean when I say have
you talked tails and light tails
okay so right so heavy tails just means
that basically here the tails of this
guy are heavier than the tails of this
guy so it means that if I draw them
they're gonna be above actually let me
keep this picture because it's gonna be
very useful for me
when I plug the quintiles at the same so
let's look at the right tail for example
right here my picture is 4 right tails
when I look at the quantiles of my
theoretical distribution so here you can
see the bottom curve we have the
theoretical quantiles and those are the
empirical quintiles the if I look to the
right here
or the theoretical quantiles larger or
smaller than the empirical quintiles let
me freeze it yellow are the empirical
quintiles larger or smaller than the
theoretical quantiles
it should be smaller right on this line
they are equal so if I see the empirical
quintile showing up here it means that
here the empirical quintile is less than
the theoretical quinta agree so that
means that if I look at this thing and
that's for the same values right so the
quintiles are computed for the same
values I over N so it means that the
empirical quintile should be looking so
that should be the empirical quintile
and that should be the theory Koch went
out agreed those are the smaller values
for the same alpha so that implies that
the tails the right tail is it's heavy
or lighter heavier or lighter than the
Gaussian ya lighter right because those
are the tails of the Gaussian those are
my theoretical quantiles that means that
this is the tail of my of my empirical
distribution so there are actually
lighter
okay so here if I look at this thing
this means that the right tail is
actually light and by light I mean
lighter than Gaussian heavy I mean
heavier than Gaussian okay okay now we
can probably do the entire thing well if
this is light this is gonna be heavy
right that's when I'm above the curve
exercise is this lighter is this heavy
the first column it's okay it should
take you at least 30 seconds yeah this
column right so this is something that
pertains this entire column is going to
tell me whether the fact that this guy
is above does this mean that I have
lighter or heavier left tails on the
Left it's heavier okay so I don't know
actually I need to draw a picture and
you guys are probably faster than I am
actually let me check how much
randomness isn't who says it's lighter
who says it's heavier yeah okay all
right so let's see if it's heavier so
we're on the left tail and so we have
one looks like this one looks like that
right so we know here that I'm looking
at this part here so it means that here
my empirical quintile is larger than the
theoretical quintile okay so are my
tails heavier or lighter they're lighter
that was a bad buys right that it's
below so it's lighter
as the problem is that larger for the
negative ones is that it's smaller and
absolutely yeah did I put this inverse
cdf know the inverse CD ends yeah so i
mean putting yeah so it's a scatter plot
right so each point is attached each
point is attached 1 over N 2 over N 3
over N now for each point I'm plotting
that's my x value which maps a number
between 0 & 1 back into the entire real
line and my Y value is the same ok so
what it means is that those two numbers
this is in the entire this lives on the
entire real line not on the interval
this lives on the entire real line not
in the interval and so my QQ plots take
values on the entire real line entire
real line all right so it's you think of
it as a parametrized curve where the the
time steps are 1 over N 2 over and
through around and I'm just like putting
a dot every time I'm making one step
okay okay so what did we say and that
was lighter right okay one of my
favorite exercises is here's a bunch of
densities here's a bunch of you Hugh
plots map the correct QQ plot to its own
density all right and and there won't be
a mingled lines that allow you to do
that then you just have to follow like
at the bat at the back of cereal boxes
all right are there any questions so one
thing there's two things I'm trying to
communicate here is if you see a QQ plot
now you should understand one how it was
built and to whether
means that you have heavier tails or
lighter tails now let's look at this guy
what should we see we should see heavy
on the left and heavy on the right right
we know that this should be the case so
this thing actually looks like this it
sort of does right if I take this line
going through here I can see that this
guy is tipping here and this guy is
dipping here but obviously actually I
can't remember exactly what T 15 if I
plotted the density on top of the
Gaussian you can see a difference but if
I just gave it to you it would be very
hard for you to tell me if there's an
actual difference between T 15 and
Gaussian right those things are actually
very close and so in particular here
we're really trying to recognize what
the shape is the fact right so T 15
compared to a standard Gaussian was
different but T 15 compared to a
Gaussian with slightly larger variance
is not gonna actually see you're not
going to see much of a difference so in
a way you know such distributions are
actually not too far from the gaussian
it's not - it's still pretty benign to
conclude that this was actually a
Gaussian distribution because you can
just you know use the variance a little
bit of a buffer I'm not gonna go really
into how you would use a T distribution
into a t-test because it's kind of like
Inception
all right so but you could pretend that
your data actually is as T distributed
and then build the T distribution from
it
but let's not say that maybe that's that
was a bad example but you know there's
like other heavy tailed distributions
like kouchi distribution which doesn't
even have it it's not even integrable so
that's as heavy as the tails get and
this you can really tell it's gonna look
like this it's gonna be like what does a
uniform distribution look like
like this it's gonna be it's gonna look
like a Gaussian one right so right so a
uniform this so this is my Gaussian a
uniform is basically gonna look like
this once I take the right mean and the
right variance right so the tails are
definitely lighter they're zero that's
as lighter as it gets so the light light
is going to look like this s-shaped
so an S light tail distribution has this
s-shaped okay what is the exponential
gonna look like right so the exponential
is positively supported it only has
positive numbers so there's no left tail
this is also as light as light as it
gets but the right tail is it heavier or
lighter than the Gaussian it's heavier
right it's only decays like e to the
minus X rather than e to the minus x
squared so it's heavier so it means that
on the left is going to be light and on
the right that's gonna be heavy so it's
gonna be you shaped okay that'll be fine
all right any other question again two
messages like more technical and you can
sort of fiddle with it by looking at it
you can definitely conclude that this is
okay enough to be Gaussian for your
purposes yeah I did not hear the if at
the beginning of your sense
so what is your purpose as a yes
yeah in a way that's true right so once
you've actually factored in the mean and
the variance the only thing that
actually right so if you have Gaussian
tails or lighter even lighter tails then
it's harder for you to explain
deviations from randomness only right if
you have a uniform distribution and you
see something which is if your uniform
on zero one plus some number and you see
25 you know this number is not gonna be
zero right so that's basically as good
as it gets and it's there's basically
some smooth interpolation if you have
lighter tails now if you start having
something that has heavy tails then it's
more likely that pure noise will
generate large observations and
therefore discovery so yes lighter tails
is definitely the best better behaved
noise let's put it this way the lighter
it is the better behaved it is now for
this is good and this is good for some
purposes but when you want to compute
actual quintiles like exact quintiles
then it it is true in general that the
quintiles of a lighter tail
distributions are going to be dominated
by the are going to be dominated by the
let's say on the right tails are gonna
be dominated by those of a heavy
distribution that is true but it's not
always the case and in particular
there's gonna be some like sort of weird
points where things are actually
changing depending on what level you're
actually looking at those things may be
5% or 10% in which case things might be
changing a little bit but if you start
going really towards the tail if you
start looking at levels alpha which are
1% or 0.1% it is true that your it's
always if you can actually so if you see
something that looks light tail you
definitely do not want to conclude that
it's Gaussian you want to actually
change your modeling so that your it
makes your life even easier and and you
actually factor in the fact that you can
see that the noise is actually more
benign that you would like it to be
okay stretching fingers that's it all
right
okay so I want to mention at some point
that we had this chi-square test that
was showing up and I do not know what I
did that's just yeah so you know we have
this chi-square test that we we worked
on last time right so the way we I
introduced the chi-square test is by
saying I am fascinated by this question
let's check if it's correct okay or
let's you know something maybe slightly
deeper let's check if juries in this
country a representative of racial
distribution but you could actually
those numbers here come from like very
specific thing that was the uniform that
was our benchmark here's the uniform and
there was the this guy which was a
benchmark which was you know the actual
benchmark that we need to have for this
problem and those things basically came
out of my hat right those are numbers
that exists but in practice you actually
make those numbers yourself and the way
you do it is by saying well if I have a
binomial distribution and I want to test
if my data comes from a binomial
distribution
you could ask this question right you
have a bunch of data I did not promise
to you that you know this was the sum of
independent bernoulli's and by and then
you can actually check that it's a
binomial indeed and you have binomial if
you think about where you've encountered
binomials
it was mostly when you were drawing
balls from urns which you probably don't
do that much in practice okay and so
maybe one day you want to model things
as a binomial or maybe you want to model
is requests so as a limited by nominal
right people tell you you know photons
arrive the rate of photon hitting some
surface is actually a Poisson
distribution right that's where they
rise a lot in imaging right so if I you
know I have a colleague who's taking
pictures of the skies overnight and is
like following stars it's just like
moving around with the rotation of the
earth and he has to do this for like you
know eight hours because he needs to get
enough photons for this picture to
actually arise India knows they arrive
but you know Poisson like a question
process and you know yeah chapter 7 of
your probability class I guess and and
you know there's all these distributions
that you know
outside the classroom you probably want
to check that they're actually correct
and so the first one you might want to
check for example is a binomial so I
give you a distribution a binomial
distribution on and say K trials and you
have some number P and here I don't know
typically what piece should be but let's
say I know it were estimated for my data
and here since we're only gonna do
asymptotics just like it was the case
for the common graph Smirnov one in the
asymptotic we're gonna be able to think
of the estimated P as being a true P
okay under no at least so now for each
outcome I can actually tell you what the
probability of a binomial is this
outcome for a given K and a given P I
can tell you exactly what the binomial
should give you as a probability for the
outcome and that's what I actually used
to replace the numbers you know one over
twelve one over twelve one over twelve
one over twelve or the numbers point
seventy two point zero seven point
twelve 0.09 all these numbers I can
actually compute using the probabilities
of a binomial right so I know for
example that the probability that a
binomial and P is equal to say K is and
choose K P to the K 1 minus P to the N
minus K okay and so these are numbers if
you give me P and you give me n I can
compute those numbers for all K from 0
to n and from this I can actually build
a table alright so for each K 0 so K is
here and from 0 1 etc all the way to n I
can compute the true probability which
is the probability that my binomial NP
is equal to 0 the probability that my
binomial is equal to 1 etc all the way
to n I can compute those numbers those
are actually going to be exact numbers
right I just plug in in the formula that
I had and then I'm gonna have some
observed
so that's going to be P hat zero and
that's basically the proportions of
zeros right so here you have to remember
it's not a one-time experiment like you
do in probability where you say I'm
gonna draw n balls from an urn and I'm
counting how many how many I have this
is statistics I need to be able to do
this experiment many times so I can
actually have in the end get an idea
what the proportion of P is so you have
not just one binomial but you have n
binomials maybe I should not use n twice
so that's why it's a k here all right so
I have a binomial thk P and I just sees
n of those guys and with this n of those
guys I can actually estimate those
probabilities and what I'm gonna want to
check if those two probabilities are
actually close to each other but I
already know how to do this alright so
here I'm going to test whether P is in
some parametric family for example
binomial or not binomial and and testing
if I know that it's a by Nolan shape I
basically just have to test if P is the
right thing okay
oh sorry I'm actually lying to you here
okay I don't want to test if it's
binomial I want to test the prove the
the probability the parameter of the
binomial here okay so I know right - no
sorry that's a sorry okay so I want to
know if I'm in some family the family of
binomials or not in the family of
binomials okay
well that's what I want to do and so
here H 0 is basically equivalent to
testing if the peaches are the PGA's
that come from the binomial and the
peaches here are the probabilities that
my I get this is the probability that I
get J successes
that's my PJ that's the J's value here
okay so this is the example and we know
how to do this we construct P hat which
is the estimated proportion of successes
from the observation so here now I have
n trials this is the actual maximum
likelihood estimator this becomes by non
multi no
experiment and right so it's kind of
confusing we have a multinomial
experiment for binomial distribution the
binomial here is just a recipe to create
some test probabilities that's all it is
my normal here it doesn't really matter
it's really to create the test
probabilities and then I'm going to
define this test statistic which is
known as the chi-square statistic right
this was the case where test we just
looked at the sum of the square root of
the differences in inverting the
covariance matrix or using the Fisher
information with removing the part that
was not invertible led us to actually
use this particular value here and then
we had to multiply by n okay and that we
know converges to what a chi-squared
distribution so I'm not gonna go through
this again I'm just telling you you can
use the chi-square that we've seen where
we we just came up with the numbers we
were testing those numbers that were in
this row for the true probabilities we
came up with them out of thin air and
now I'm telling you you can actually
come up with those guys from a binomial
distribution or a Poisson distribution
or whatever distribution you're happy
with any question so now I'm creating
this thing and I can apply the entire
theory that it has for the chi-square
and in particular that this thing
converges to a chi-square but if you see
there's something that's different what
is different the degrees of freedom and
if you think about it again
the meaning of degrees of freedom what
does this word in this words actually
mean it means well to which extent can I
play around with those values what are
the possible values that I can get if
I'm not equal to this particular value
I'm testing how many directions can I be
different from this guy and when we had
like a given set of values we could be
any other set of values right so here I
had this I'm gonna represent this is the
set of all probability distributions of
vectors of a certain of size K so he
if I look at one point in this set this
is something that looks like P 1 to P K
such that there's some so such that
they're non-negative and the sum P 1 to
P K is equal to 1 okay so I have all
this points here okay so this is
basically the set that I had before if I
was testing whether I was equal to this
one guy or if I was anything else and
there's many ways that can be anything
else what matters of course is what's
around this guy that could I could
actually confuse me myself with but
there's many ways I can move around this
guy agreed now I'm actually just testing
something very specific I'm saying well
now the piece that I have have to come
from this have to be constructed from
this formula this parametric family P of
theta and there's a very you know
there's a fixed way for let's say this
is Theta so I have a theta here there's
not that many ways this can actually
give me a set of probabilities right I
can I have to move to another theta to
actually start being confused and so
here the number of degrees of freedom is
basically how can I move along this
family and so here this is all the
points but there might be just the
subset of the points that looks like
this just this curve not a half half of
saying and those guys on this curves are
the P theta and that's for all Thetas
when theta runs across theta so in a way
this is just this much smaller
dimensional thing it's a much smaller
object those are the only the ones that
I can create that are exactly of this
very specific parametric form and not of
course not all are of this form that all
probability pmfs are of this form and so
that is going to have an effect on what
my PMF is going to be I'm sorry I'm what
my my sorry what my degrees of freedoms
are gonna be because when this thing is
very small
right that means when that's happening
when theta is actually say a
one-dimensional space then there's still
many ways I can escape right I can be
different from this guy in pretty much
every other direction except for those
two directions just when I move from
here or when I move in this direction
but now if this thing becomes bigger
your theta is say 2 dimensional then
when I'm here it's becoming harder for
me to not be that guy if I want to move
away from it I have to move away from
the board and so that means that the
bigger the dimension of my of my theta
the smaller the degrees of freedoms that
I have okay because moving out of this
parametric family is actually very
difficult for me so if you think for
example as the at an extreme case the
parametric family that I have is
basically all pmf's all of them right so
that's the stupid parametric family I'm
indexed by the distribution itself but
it's still finite dimensional then here
I have basically no degrees of freedom
there's no way I can actually not be
that guy because this is everything I
have and so you don't have to really
understand what the how the computation
comes in into into the numbers of
dimension and what I mean by dimension
of this curved space but really what's
important is that as the dimension of
theta becomes bigger I have less degrees
of freedom to become to be away from
this family this family becomes big and
it's very hard for me to violate this so
it's actually shrinking the number of
degrees of freedom of my of my Chi
square and that's all you need to
understand when D increases the number
of degrees of freedom decreases and if
you'd like to you to have an idea of why
this is somewhat true and this is
basically the picture you should have in
mind okay so now once I have done this I
can just construct so here I need to
check so what is D in the case of the
binomial one right it's just a
one-dimensional thing for most of the
examples we're gonna have it's going to
be one dimensional so we have this weird
thing we're gonna have K minus 2 the
of freedom so now I have this thing and
and I have this asymptotic Nana can just
basically use a test that has that uses
the fact that the asymptotic
distribution is this so I compute my
quintiles out of this again I made the
same mistake this should be Q alpha and
this should be Q alpha so that's just
the tail probability is equal to alpha
when I'm on the right of Q alpha and so
those are the tail probability of the
appropriate chi-square really
appropriate the number of degrees of
freedom and so I can compute p-values
and I can do whatever I want
okay so then I just like and fold my
testing machinery okay so now I know how
to test a binomial distribution or not
again here I testing if I'm a binomial
distribution is not a simple goodness of
fit it's a composite one where I can
actually there's many ways I can be a
binomial distribution because there's as
many as there is theta and so I'm
actually plugging in the theta hat which
is estimated from the data right and
here since everything's happening in the
asymptotics I'm not claiming that TN has
a pivotal distribution for finite n this
is actually not true it's gonna depend
like crazy on what the actual
distribution is but as some tonically I
have a chi-square which obviously does
not depend on anything I don't know okay
yeah
yeah
that's correct
and thank you for this beautiful segue
into my next slide so we can actually
deal with the case not only where it's
infinite which would be the case of
Poisson I mean nobody believes I'm gonna
get an infinite number of photons in a
finite time but we just don't want to
have to say there's gonna be a large
this is the largest possible number we
don't want to have to do that because if
you start doing this then the
probabilities become close to zero
things become degenerate and it's an
issue so what we do is we've been we
just been stuff okay and so maybe you
know if I have a binomial distribution
with say 200,000 possible values then
it's actually maybe not the level of
precision I want to look at this maybe I
want to bin maybe I want to say let's
just think of all things that are
between zero and 100 to be the same
thing between 100 and 200 the same thing
etc and so if I actually I'm actually
gonna bin I don't even have to think
about things that are discrete I can't
even think about continuous cases and so
if I want to test if I have a Gaussian
distribution for example I can just
approximate that by some say piecewise
constant function that just says that
well you know if I have a Gaussian
distribution like this I'm gonna bin it
like this and I'm gonna say well the
probability that I'm less than this
value is this the probability of M
between this and this value is this the
program between this and this value is
this and then this and then this right
and now I've turned I've discretized
effectively my Gaussian into a PMF the
value that this is p1 the value here is
p1 this is p2 this is p3
this is p4 this is p5 and p6 right
they've discretize my Gaussian into six
possible values that's just the
probability that they fall into a
certain bin and we can do this if you if
you don't know what K is just stop at 10
you know let's look you look at your
data quickly and you say well you know I
have so few of them that are like I see
maybe
one eight one eleven and one fifteen
well everything that's between eight and
twenty I'm just gonna put in one bin
because what else are you gonna do I
mean you just don't have enough
observation and so what we do is we just
been everything so here I'm gonna
actually be slightly abstract our bins
are gonna be intervals AJ so here they
don't even have to be intervals I could
go crazy and just like call the bin this
guy and this guy right that would make
no sense but I could do that and and
then I'm and of course you know you can
do whatever you want but there's gonna
be some consequences and the conclusions
that you can take right all you're gonna
be able to say is that my distribution
does not look like it could be bend in
this way that's all you're gonna be able
to say so if you decide to just put all
the negative numbers and the positive
numbers then it's gonna be very hard for
you to distinguish a Gaussian from a
random variable that takes values minus
one and plus one only you need to just
you know be reasonable okay so now I
have my PJs become the probability that
my random variable falls into being J so
that's P G of theta under the parametric
distribution for the true one whether
it's parametric or not I have a PJ and
then I have a P hat J which is the
proportion of observations that falls in
this bin all right so I have a bunch of
observations I count how many of them
fall in this bin I divide by n and that
tells me what my estimated probability
for this bin is and theta hat well it's
the same as before if I'm in a
parametric family I'm just estimating
theta hat may be a maximum likelihood
estimator plug it in and estimate those
PG of theta hat from this I form my
chi-square and I have exactly the same
thing as before so the answer to your
question is yes you've been and it's the
answer to even more questions so that's
why there you can actually use the
chi-square test to test for normality
now here it's going to be slightly
weaker because there's only an
asymptotic theory whereas
kolmogorov-smirnov and Kolmogorov Lefors
work actually even for finite samples
for for the chi-square test it's only
asymptotic so you just pretend you
actually know what the parameters are
just stuff them into theta a mu hat and
Sigma square hat and you just go to you
just cross your finger that n is long
enough for everything to have converged
by the time you make your decision okay
and then this is a copy paste with the
same error actually as the previous
slide where you just build your test
based on whether you exceed or not some
quintile and you can also compute some
p-value okay I'm sorry
what is the error oh the air is that
this should be Q alpha right I've been
calling this Q alpha I mean that's my
personal choice because I don't want to
I only use Q alpha so I only use 20
hours of degree and where alpha is to
the right so that's what statisticians
probably would use this this notation
okay and so some questions right so of
course in practice you're gonna have
some issues which you know translate I
said well how do you pick this guy this
case so I gave you some sort of you know
I mean the way we discuss right you have
8 and 10 and 20 then it's you know it's
a hawk and so depending on whether you
want to stop K at 20 or if you want to
bend those guys is really up to you and
there's gonna be some considerations
about the particular problem at hand I
mean is it course-to-course for your
problem to decide that the observations
between 8 and 20 are the same it's
really up to you maybe that's actually
making a huge difference in terms of
what phenomenon you're looking at the
choice of the bins right so here there's
actually some sort of rules which are
don't use only one bin and don't make
sure there's actually at least don't use
them too small so that there's at least
one observation per bin right and it's
basically the same kind of rules that
you would have to build a histogram if
you were to build a histogram for your
data you still want to make sure that
you've been inappropriately
ok and there's a bunch of rule of thumbs
every time you ask someone they're gonna
have a different rule of thumb so you
know just make your own and and then
there's the computation of P G of theta
which might be a bit complicated because
in this case I would have to integrate
the Gaussian between this number and
this number
so for this case I could just say well
this difference of the CDF in that value
and that value and then be happy with it
but you can imagine that you have some
slightly more crazy distributions you're
gonna have to somewhat compute some
integrals that might be unpleasant for
you to compute okay and in particular I
said the difference of the PDF between
that value and that value of sorry the
CDF between that value and that value it
is true but it's not like you actually
have tables that compute the CDF at any
value you like right you have to sort of
you know well there might be but at some
degree but you're gonna have to use a
computer typically to do that okay and
so for example you could do the Poisson
if I had time if I had more than one
minute I would actually do it for you
but it's basically the same the Poisson
you're gonna have an infinite tail and
you just say at some point I'm gonna cut
everything that's larger than some value
all right so you can play around for
some right I say well if you have extra
knowledge about what you expect to see
maybe you can cut that a certain number
and then just fold all the largest
values from K minus one to infinity so
that you actually have you have
everything into one large bin okay
that's the entire tail and that's the
way people do it in insurance companies
for example they assume that the number
of accidents you're going to have is a
Poisson distribution they have to fit it
to you they have to know or at least to
Europol of insurance of insured people
so they just you know slice you into you
know what your character relevant
characteristics are and then they want
to estimate what the Poisson
distribution is and basically they do
they can do a chi-square test to check
if it's indeed a Poisson distribution
all right so that will be it for today
and so I'll be I'll have your home